running for salah. No noise.
Alhamdulillah. This is a huge blessing
when we are able to uphold the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam sunnah
and ourselves and in our peers and our
neighbors.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
The next few verses or actually the
remaining verses
of
are
Paul speaking about with generalities
but specifically were revealed regarding
a man referred to most commonly and most
commonly known as Abu Jah. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala begins the chapter
of Alak mentioning the incredible
amounts of blessings that Allah has
bestowed upon the human being.
He has created the human being from
drops and clots and small lumps of
flesh. He puts a soul into this
creature. He takes it through stages,
very very precise stages.
And then he brings forth a creature that
is so intelligent
that he is able to understand
from the words of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. He is able to recite the literal
words of Allah.
Yet he is a creation and a creature of
Allah. A creature of intellect, a
creature of free will. A creature that
was meant for more than just
the material world. A creature that's
not just driven by chemicals or
driven by biology. It's a creature that
has a will, has an intellect, has a
higher purpose, and is able through this
higher purpose and this knowledge to
transcend the physical world around him.
A truly incredible creature. The human
being is Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us
indeed we have
greatly honored
the son of Adam the child of Adam.
This is one of the most important
lessons for us to learn
from the book of Allah, especially in
our time, in our place amongst popular
opinions that would have us believe
otherwise. And this is one of the most
important lessons that we have to teach
our children. What What do we have to
teach our children? that you are a human
being.
That is a huge honor and you are unlike
any other creature on this earth. You
are meant for a high purpose and your
life is inherently valuable.
This is something which is often
overlooked in our society.
Why is suicide so prevalent?
Why are people by the hundreds every
single year, every year,
by the hundreds, people come to the
Grand Canyon here in Arizona
and fall off the side of the cliff
trying to take a selfie? Why does that
happen? If a person could really think
about this, weighing the risks and the
benefits, right?
I stand at the edge of this cliff. The
greatest benefit I'm looking for is I'm
going to get a really nice picture of
myself. But what's at risk? What am I
risking for this picture?
I am risking death or permanent
disability.
That's what I'm risking. And then go
ahead and think that that is and
determine that that is worth risking
their life.
We see addiction, drug use. We see
people that do stunts where they jump
off of buildings or do all of these
crazy things risking
their lives. Risking their only chance
at paradise.
Why? For a laugh.
Sacrificing their dignity for a laugh.
That's the most they'll get out of it.
someone will laugh at them
or
a person's greatest achievement for
risking their life is some money or
something of that sort. This is
where people are at right now. This is
where their minds are at.
Why is that?
Because human beings in this time and in
this place
they do not value their lives.
They don't see themselves as being
valuable.
And so
we see that all of this is for what
reason? What's the reason people are
risking their lives and limbs? It's for
silly things because they don't value
their lives. What is one of the greatest
reasons they do not value their lives?
It is a disbelief. It is not knowing
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. It is that
they have been taught that they're just
a creature amongst the creatures of
earth. Right? They're just a creature
from amongst the creatures of earth.
It's very interesting when you look at
the concept and the theory, although
it's really not a theory. It's more of,
you know, , , it's more of a tall
tale, but this alleged scientific theory
of Darwinian evolution, very interesting
because
what Darwin thought and what his
intellect and he was he was a very
intelligent man. But an a misguided or
unguided mind that is not guided by
revelation is a mind that will only
increase its host in pain and suffering.
And so what was his theory? His theory
is well everything began from a common
ancestor.
Everything started from a common
organism and then life slowly slowly
slowly
started to randomly mutate
and started to grow in different
directions because these different
organisms are seeking sustenance,
right? It's a it's the law of supply
and demand. So after being bacteria for
a really really really long time, some
lightning hit the water or a bunch of
different theories that have come up
over the years and suddenly we have fish
swimming around and then the fish
decided, you know what, it's really
crowded in here and I think that I
could go up on the beach there and
probably find some food there that
nobody is going to be competing with me
for. So this fish decided to flop up on
the on the beach and then his children,
his offspring and offspring and
offspring over, you know, and then they
throw these these numbers around
thousands and tens of thousands and
billions of years and all of this stuff.
and fish kept flopping up on the beach.
And then finally they started to grow
little legs and they walked up on the
beach. And then some of the fish looked
up at the trees and said, "You know
what? It would be great if I had a tail.
It would be great if I had thumbs. It
would be great if I grew some wings so I
could fly around." And then after all
this time, here we are. The origin of
the species. I just gave you a synopsis
of that book, right? And I know it
sounds silly what I'm telling you right
now, but if you've read the book many
times, if you've read the work that's
written on this book and this alleged
theory, that's what it sums up. That's
what it is. And so what does this what
concept is the core concept of this kind
of book or this kind of idea? The human
being is not special.
The human being is not special. The
human being came from the same origins
that everything else on earth came from.
That's the that's the that is the end
result or the conclusion of this. So
what was Charles Darwin's
second book that he wrote right after
the origin of species? He wrote another
book after that.
expounding upon that theory. What was
his next book? The descent of man. Of
course, the descent of man. Because
human beings always thought that they
were special. But there's nothing
special about humans. They came from the
same place that everything else came
from. And so this concept is not
understood even by the person who
originally came up with it.
But it gave people who wanted to
disbelieve
in Allah an argument, some kind of an
argument.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
those who have illness and misguidance
in their heart,
these are the kinds of people that hold
on to ambiguous things and interpret
them in the way that they want to bring
out the conclusion that they are looking
for. And so the descent of man is really
the conclusion of such a theory. And
this theory has become so widespread
that it almost to the untrained eye, you
would think that scientists really
believe this theory, but they do not.
And if you are a scientist who gets
grants and need to continue your
experiments and need to continue your
research and your livelihood and you
want to come out and tell people that
this is a disproven theory that's
actually comically silly and has no
connection in reality other than very
vague strings.
Say goodbye to your reputation. Say
goodbye to your funding. Say goodbye to
a lot of things. And this is why it has
become so widespread.
But the people, the layman people on the
bottom, just the regular people that go
to a public school, that go to college,
for instance, and they don't research
deep enough to get to the ends of these
things. They only hear of the theory. to
them they take the they take the you
know the conclusion and they run with
it. And so even people who believe in a
creator,
even people who are Christian or Jew,
they have tried to find a way to believe
in this theory.
And even the Catholic Church, its
official
position is Darwinian evolution and that
it is a correct theory that it is almost
scientifically proven. But it's not and
the more science advances the more that
it is disproven.
However,
people understood the final conclusion
which was what human beings are not
special.
Human beings are just the same as every
other creature. And this is where we get
people saying things they're a
cat a cat mom or a dog dad, right?
Looking at their pets as if they're
their children, their flesh and blood.
Maybe they haven't spoken to their own
flesh and blood for years, decades.
But if their pet dies, they will grieve
that pet as if they have lost a
relative. Right? I've known people that
have had to take grieving grieving leave
from work because they are too broken up
over the death of their cat or dog,
right? And they try to give rights. We
have instances where millionaires and
billionaires leave their fortunes to
their dogs.
leave as the heir of their fortunes dogs
and cats even though they have kids and
children that are human beings. Why is
this? Where does all this come from?
This all comes from the idea that human
beings are just everything else.
There's no difference between human
beings and the other creatures or
animals on this earth. It is an
incredibly
destructive theory that most people I
would venture as to say most people you
meet especially in the west they believe
in this theory or aspects of it have
rubbed off on them and colored the way
that they see the world around them.
communism, fascism, over 80 million
deaths
or or casualties just in the 20th
century alone all root back to Darwinian
evolution.
The Marx brothers, Engles and Marx,
wrote their communist manifesto and it
was a social aspect or implementation of
Darwinian evolution
and so on it goes. This idea this this
this extremely dangerous idea and
that idea is that the human being is not
special is not meant for anything
special. the human being is an accident.
Only the events that led to evolution.
And so people also believe the opposite
of that, that there's aliens, and the
aliens are going to come from other
planets, and they're far more advanced
than we are because of evolution.
All of this comes from this this
brain parasite that has nestled its way
into the minds. And not just for us to
sit and say, well, you know, the
non-Muslims believe this. No, your
children are being taught this right now
in school.
Every one of our children that has gone
to public school knows this theory
through and through. And so this is why
there is such and this is why the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said
that just before
emerges on the earth one of the signs
one of the things that will occur is
that blood will become very cheap.
People will spill human blood and not
think twice about it. And so we have
arrived at such a junction. And you look
at movies for instance, you know, maybe
the older gentlemen amongst us here
could remember or some of the older
sisters could remember when cinema was a
very small part of a person's life. And
if there was a a movie where someone
shoots another person, it's off camera.
It's just, you know, it's play. You can
see it's play. Now a person will watch a
movie and you will literally see
people's guts coming out and their heads
exploding and blood baths. Why is this?
This is the these are the symptoms of a
people who have no respect for life. As
a matter of fact, they positively
despise
the human being. And this all comes from
the original whispers of a shan to Adam.
That when those angels fell in
prostration to Adam, one of the biggest
things that a shaitan has worked to try
to convince us as human beings is that
we did not deserve for those angels to
prostrate to us. We deserve eternal
damnation. In
We ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he subhanahu wa ta'ala teach us and
teach our children protect us and
protect our children that he subhanahu
wa ta'ala grant us the understanding
knowledge and the success to rise to the
potential that he has endowed in usam
[Arabic recitation]
origins. But even Jewish rabbis are
unclear as to whether Judaism is a
religion or a race. It's a difference of
opinion.
[Arabic recitation]
but he was atheist in his beliefs. Now,